foreign
Brooke is in Hattiesburg Mississippi hi
Brooke what's up
hey Dave hey George how are you guys
better than we deserve how can we help
so this is a money question but it's
mostly an emotional psychological
question I think
um my husband and I want your advice on
whether or not we should go home to
visit family for Christmas this year uh
the back story for that is that we live
here in Mississippi and both of our
families live in the North and every
year it's our routine to stop in Ohio go
to New York and come back because we're
the only ones that live in the south my
husband is getting his PhD in genetics
at USM
uh I'm super proud of him about that so
uh and we have the only grandchild
on both sides of the family uh so
everyone very much wants to see us yeah
you have a great you have great bait
come see us if you want to see the
grandchild Mississippi
the Mississippi Christmas oh yeah and
she's she's the sweetest too I love her
but anyway
um so we've been working our baby steps
and it has been
a bit of an uphill battle with you know
with my husband still in his um PhD
program
and I'm trying as best as I can to be a
stay-at-home mom and uh still bring in
uh the income that we need to do
everything we need to do but we've uh
paid off probably close to twenty
thousand dollars in debt and the last
that we are uh that we have left is
about five thousand dollars left on a
credit card I would choose to spend this
Christmas in Mississippi and invite
everyone to come see you
and if they don't want to go that was
their choice and you guys are gonna have
a great little Christmas one year
one year and they can they're more than
welcome we'd love to have them nobody's
mad at anybody we just can't do it this
year
I'm so sorry
um you know by the way when you go
through your life it changes as to who
visits who with the the different phases
of your life